you know and this was actually the
moment where the light bulb went off for
me as the as the brand guy of like
we have such reach and we're we're a
central service and before the term
essential was kind of becoming more
talked about like
you know people rely on us for basic
transportation and work
every single day in you know 10 000
cities around the world
so we have an ultimate responsibility to
show up in a way that
assures people that we're there for them
and they need us assures them they can
help them move safely but also partners
with governments to make sure we're
getting the right information out
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
we're super fired up to have you awesome
nice to be here and that's a hard act to
follow
you're gonna follow it though brother i
have a lot of admiration for you we
haven't had too much
interacting through our years but i'm
really excited to have you here and i i
really do admire a lot of your work
same thank you great to be here why
don't you why don't we set the
foundation for context just a little
personal stuff share a bit about
yourself sure sure
um yeah i think andrea who i've known
for many years
i think some summarized it well um i've
had a pretty pretty unconventional past
i often wonder how how did i get into
marketing what am i doing here
um i've done lots of different things in
my career from wanting to be an aspiring
actor as a kid to
um to spending a long time actually in
policy and government i've worked at
every level of government city state
and federal uh including a stint in the
clinton administration
um and also worked for elliot spitzer
when i was the first
uh cmo for the state of new york didn't
know that
the i love new york brand was a state
campaign and a state asset as a kid who
grew up in brooklyn
that was actually the eye-opening thing
when i sat down with the administration
to hear wow the state owns the brand
like what can we do with that it's
pretty exciting
um you know i went to the dark side i
worked at mckinsey and
banking and then um and then you know
what's the biggest thing what's the
biggest thing you learned from those
kind of hardcore institutions
oh you know that um you can do anything
if you break a problem down into its
pieces
i think the mckinsey training was
actually some of the most painful years
of my life with some of the most
incredible learnings
and there's sort of an arrogance if you
want to call it that a mckinsey of like
we can solve any problem because if you
apply the rigor and break things down to
its pieces and then figure out how to
tackle them
you actually could solve almost anything
do you feel that it breaks down
on the humanity side because that's
always been my observation
in looking at mckinsey which i admire so
much the process
is right but so is the process of
playing basketball perfectly the problem
is not everybody's lebron james
yeah well i think the challenge you have
and like one of my learnings from having
been both in the public and private
sectors is in some ways the private
sector is a whole lot easier because the
what you're optimizing for is pretty
clear and measurable usually it's some
sort of business
result whereas in the in the public
sector they're just
you know there's so many stakeholders
and confounding interests and it's
really not clear what success looks like
or how you measure it
i think i mean i mean by the way you
just
can somebody clip that for me because
that just sums up my life
everything i try to talk about from i
mean that's that's
what an entrepreneur's life that has
always run family businesses that the
health of your well-being is based on
the health of the business
working with fortune 5000 companies
which is the antithesis of that
to your to the way that you just
recapped it but i have to say that
training as well being in government is
incredible for being in business
particularly in these days because
like it's about managing stakeholders
frankly the bottom line is getting
redefined and the role of brands and
businesses in the community and society
and policy
i think has evolved a ton and it's you
know it's true brands and businesses can
play a strong role in positive change
like
so i think this whole conversation is
actually coming around which
is why actually now that i look back in
my career i'm like i've i feel really
fortunate to have done some really
interesting things and it followed my
heart and
glad i didn't take that linear path um
because i've got a lot more interesting
experiences to draw on for the work that
i'm doing today
which which is great so yeah so i spent
a decade at google was really attracted
to
to the the leadership of the company and
the mission
and the power of google i joined when it
was a whole lot smaller than it was
today it was 20 000 people
um and it felt so like it had that
startup energy and changed the world and
did some really interesting things i was
the first
head of strategy i was the first um i
was the founder of the brand studio i
was the first person to run
marketing for hardware before we even
had a hardware business
that's cool um i had some really
exciting uh adventures there
and then um you know i jumped shipped to
join uber about 10 months ago which
feels like 10 years ago having lived
through the pandemic i'm living through
yeah i mean my timing right
um but i have to say you know it's a
it's not a it's not wasn't a natural
decision for me to join uber i'll say
you know
when they called me i said i'm not sure
you want me to lead marketing i was one
of the folks who joined the lead uber in
the heyday
um but i really came to respect dara and
the fact that the company is not the
company that it was
um and it could be a really powerful
force for good
and talk about bringing public and
private interest together
imagine the input the infrastructure
that uber has in place
and lyft and and just the general
infrastructure is extraordinary
and uh and to your point things evolve
tremendously over time
yeah we have new leadership i think we
have the right leadership i think it's a
company that has
had has learned many lessons from its
past let's just say that
and if you could imagine the like
leveraging the reach and the power and
frankly the brashness and the boldness
of what you think of uber imagine
leveraging that
to redefine work leveraging that to get
cities to be more sustainable leveraging
that to fight the pandemic like
that's kind of the company in the brand
you want to be taking on these world
problems and so
how do we harness that energy and that
intent which i do believe is
is in the company have you uh have you
interacted with travis freeman yet
all right uh former executive uh at
vayner who who's there so
rabbits my travis sorry yeah you're
tracking it i was thinking as
i was thinking infamous travis and i
just went no no no
did they not interact yet i guess this
covert thing is crazy interact i am like
i am like every day right i figured i
figured
no problem
he's the best dude of all time i'm sure
he if he was
if he's watching he's not busy he was
like what the hell
exactly no travis talk to me talk to me
about talk to me about
10 months in a lot of people can relate
to this 10 months into a new gig
you're just getting your feet underneath
you boom the probably the biggest
single event that any of us have gone
through in
uh in our careers and for some people
our lives
how difficult was that obviously uber
itself in its core business was
you know some businesses have flourished
during this time this is a real
challenge for uber's core business
obviously we see the uh
the the postmates news and different
things like what give us a little 4-1-1
on the chaos and maybe some insights
that might be able to help other people
that are going through chaos or one day
will
yeah good question well in some ways
uber has been
well trained at crises right um so it's
a company that
actually goes into it's it's like into
its best mode
when a crisis hits i have to say it's an
incredibly rigorous operational company
um and so we actually organized and
scenario planned
well in february before things kind of
really were clear where they were
heading i mean i was still keeping
travel on the books until the end of
march thinking yeah i'm gonna go to
india in april i'm still going
oh i had this i had this so wrong i was
like okay if everything goes atrocious
and this was like in march atrocious
we'll all definitely be back by fourth
of july if it goes
a tr that was my like catastrophic
timing so i i can resonate with that go
ahead
we had a leadership uh company-wide
leadership summit planned in person in
february and dara called it off but said
you know those who are still willing to
travel
should and a small group of us came
together over three full days
every function of the company
represented about a group of 40 people
to really think through what does this
mean what are the different ways this
could play out
and frankly what's our role like what
how should we show up in this
you know and this was actually the
moment where the light bulb went off for
me as the as the brand guy of like
we have such reach and we're we're a
central service before the term
essential was kind of becoming more
talked about like
you know people rely on us for basic
transportation and work
every single day in you know 10 000
cities around the world
so we have an ultimate responsibility to
show up in a way that
assures people that we're there for them
and they need us assures them they can
help them move safely but also partners
with governments to make sure we're
getting the right information out
and in many ways we are you could say
like you know we're a basic service
and so it i coined the term early that
this is an
opportunity for us and a need for us to
show up like a citizen leader
you know we're we need to be a leader as
a brand and as a company of our size but
we also need to be a citizen and really
be part of the communities and cities
that we're working
in and the countries and really figure
out how to help address the virus
and so you know some principles like
let's stay close to government
authorities and make sure that we're
communicating what the health
authorities are communicating
make sure we're keeping the business
open where we're essential but also
really frankly urging people not to ride
if that's what's clear to
clearly going to stop the virus um and
so
it became a kind of a moment to
articulate those values and to do what
dara
has urged the company to do since you
joined just to do the right thing
and really not not just think about the
business but think about the people in
the community speaking of which there's
a good transition
thank you for not riding with uber
that very much caught my attention
please explain that and maybe that maybe
you can connect those two dots
sure yeah so taking everything i just
said i mean we actually very early
put a lot of um health authority
information into our app
because you know people were going to
our app on a regular basis
and so communicating what the
authorities were telling the
the cities and the countries that we're
in in terms of what's safe and how they
should operate how should they move so
we were very early to do that in fact we
put some messaging pretty early in our
app that said flatten the curve
you know only ride if you need to so
encouraging people to just think twice
and so then we came up with this idea to
communicate that message more broadly
because it was
obvious that what we needed to do to
address the virus is just stop movement
and what better company and brand to
tell people to stop move
than the movement brand the company
that's always stood for movement
so you might argue it could have been a
career limiting move to have the first
campaign i go to dara to ask for is like
can we run an
ad that says don't write our product
and we did um you know he definitely
paused he's like are you sure we really
want to say that on television
um but it was the right thing to say and
it felt like the responsible thing to do
and frankly had that kind of response um
that i think you had which is it stopped
people to realize actually it must be a
really important message to come from
uber
because it's not in our interest to
actually be saying that big shout out to
jim davis for the kind words of this
show
giving you some love thomas and the
others hashtag marketing for them now
if you've got insights quotes things of
that nature we love watching you all on
twitter
thomas what about what about the speed
in which we all have to navigate now
um you come from a background that i
think especially in google times like
speed was a variable
hence your point even it was 20 000 it
was still a very
fast company do you feel
that the zooms google hangouts
slacks email text like do you think the
infrastructure from remote working
is actually leading to more speed i do i
mean i've been calling the work that
we've been doing and i've travis and i
talk about this as real-time marketing
i mean there's never been more real-time
marketing than the last you know four or
so months
um i mean you know the spot that we just
referred to thank you
thank you riders we created in three
days
we're running a spot now no mask no ride
also i think a really important message
and so while we're open for
business we want people to realize a
mask actually not just keeps you safe it
keeps everyone around you safe and
frankly we need to keep our drivers safe
um and so and we created that spot in
three days as well so like
and so for the first few months we were
doing focus groups three days a week
every week
in every country because we just needed
to stay close to kind of how things were
changing how people were perceiving
things and we're still
trying to stay keep our pulse on things
because this is evolving in ways that
are just unprecedented
and so doing work being responsive we've
pivoted i mean we were ready to run the
no mass spot the week of the
black lives matter protest that occurred
and so we quickly pivoted and said
that's not the right message right now
and put that on the shelf
you don't know when we'll run that and
then we pivot it back as the debate is
kind of raged up around that mass so
like
i mean it's like we're looking out a few
months but i don't i don't feel like i
can look out more than eight weeks
without any real sense of like what we
should be doing
tapping into your uncomfortable
likability that you're
possessing here on this
i'm just genuinely curious about you the
dude uh
any behavior shifts from you that you're
most intrigued by
new shows new apps buying something new
direct to consumer that you never
thought you would and now you can never
go back
anything hit your radar if you're self
evaluating
i like that you're looking out to yonder
so you're thinking and you know
any anything that really stands out to
you about maybe a new consumer trend
from you maybe a new ott
platform maybe uh the way you consume
news
anything stand out it's so funny if
anything my my mind quickly goes to
the human things that i'm doing and
doing more regularly like
like going to walk the dog in the park
every morning despite the stress of the
day that's about to come
has that been a wonderful addition to
your life having dinner at the dinner
the dinner table not the kitchen counter
with my partner every day with proper
table clothes not tablecloths
probably just like a proper city
settings yeah not using your hands to
eat more you know
so like actually those moments have been
the more memorable my partner is
shopping online more than i'd like so
we've got too much cardboard and
recycling i keep complaining about that
so
he's leaned into that behavior um but i
have to say it's been more trying to
embrace the
human connections in this and reaching
out to friends and family that i haven't
talked to in
in a long time actually that's been sort
of more memorable to me
um than some of the technology that
maybe i've always used or just
i'm a slow adopter too well
the the affirmation to your incredible
likability has been confirmed on twitter
i knew it i was feeling it uh and uh i
will be texting travis right now to make
sure we get to chop up and spend some
time together i really appreciate you
and your insights
and i wish you nothing but health thanks
for having me good luck
bye hey everybody on youtube first of
all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out